some very sad news coming out of New
Zealand a fire which broke out overnight
at a four-story hospital hostel in the
capital uh Wellington has caused the
deaths of at least six people according
to the prime minister of New Zealand
Chris Hipkins six people have been
confirmed dead but there could be more
fatalities this is a picture of the
hostel the fire broke out at about half
past 12 in the morning Wellington fire
and emergency district manager Nick Piet
said 52 people have been accounted for
but that number could change I can sadly
report this will be a multi-fatality
incident he said our thoughts at this
time are with the families of those
who've perished and with our crews who
valiantly rescued those they could six
people at least died in a hostile fire
in Wellington in New Zealand